panamá se sumó a la ola de protestas
latinoamericanas de los últimos años un
descontento que coincide con la invasión
de rusia a ucrania guerra que ha
trastocado las economías de todo el
mundo pero que ha desnudado problemas
estructurales
ya son más de dos semanas de las
protestas más grandes desde la caída en
1989 del dictador manuel antonio noriega
se empiezan a ver imágenes de
desabastecimiento por los cortes de vía
en unas marchas iniciadas por maestros
ya las que se fueron sumando otros
sectores desde la construcción hasta el
movimiento indígena
la inflación interanual se sitúa en un
42 % los principales reclamos son
consecuencia del golpe al bolsillo del
ciudadano el precio del combustible
aumentó en un 47 por ciento en los
últimos seis meses y el galón llegó a
superar los cinco dólares antes de ser
reducido por el gobierno el índice de
precios al consumidor aumentó en un 33 %
respecto a 2021 por lo que también se
han congelado el aumento del coste de 10
alimentos de la canasta básica
más allá del momento panamá tiene 4
millones de habitantes el 20% de la
población vive en condiciones de pobreza
y la mitad trabaja en empleos informales
eso en un país que en 2021 creció un 17
8% y que posee un canal que le reporta 2
mil millones de dólares al año sin
embargo es uno de los países más
desiguales en el mundo con frecuentes
casos de corrupción como el popular
macro caso de la constructora brasileña
odebrecht que salpica a los dos últimos
ex presidentes